ja ich da sagt machte
was es geht und sie bekommen mit einem
brandneuen spiel es geht direkt los wir
spielen heute mein worauf botnet und
besonders die kisten eines ist ein
relativ neues spiel monate wurde gerade
erst gelauncht die idee ist schon ein
bisschen älter aber es hat sozusagen ein
relaunch stattgefunden
und wir spielen jetzt hier die maps
wirklich brandneuen modus denkt der ist
glaube ich seit zwei oder drei tagen
online hier die open beta und es ist
richtig cool
also schaut euch auf jeden fall an vor
allen dingen auch deswegen weil heute
auch in relativ interessant das thema
diskutieren werden und zwar dürfen
manches mitbekommen haben dass das ein
oder andere nacktfoto da im internet
aufgetaucht ist nur anderem von kate
upton von jennifer lawrence und vielen
anderen
und ja das war doch mal durchaus krass
würde ich sagen oder weil das war ja
wirklich einfach so private weist so
ganz private hast du ja eigentlich ja
ich hatte nicht gesehen wo sind die denn
nu die sind ich weiß nicht ob ich das
jetzt sagen kann leute vielleicht
überlege ich mir noch im laufe des
videos vielleicht sagen ist ganz am ende
für alle die dabei geblieben sind so
dass wir mal eine gute idee was haltet
ihr davon
da wird nix gestreikt ist jackie stewart
haben den ersten kinder unten in der 3
otto hat das ganze team orange matif
ging an das team gold ab das gleiche
raus sondern gold hab mich jetzt
komplett auseinandergenommen
also man tritt in teams gegeneinander an
und kämpft wacker auf leben und tod
manchmal kurz versucht das gegnerische
team zu eliminieren
das kannst du auf trap sehen ramon ist
hier ein team gold also rolle ich es
gesagt bin im team love is und es
letzten endes geht es darum das
gegnerische team einfach komplett aus zu
löschen
und das funktioniert so man einfach wie
gesagt diese kisten ein
in diesen kisten beziehungsweise aus
diesen kisten erhält man zufällig
entweder in stein schwert und bogen 32
feile oder eine leder display und dann
zieht man los in den krieg und wenn man
kills holt dann seht ihr da unten da wo
eigentlich die erfahrung versteht die
level kommt dann mit ihren kindern eine
zahl dazu
und für diese punkte die daten angezeigt
sind kann man sich dann im shop items
kaufen unter anderem auch den
vollautomatischen bogen creeper feile
und paar andere sachen also ziemlich
geil da vorne ist schon gut da vorne ist
und ich glaube es kann jetzt bin ich da
nein nein
von hinten bei gold seal hat mir
geholfen auf jeden fall das ist ein sehr
sehr sehr geile spiel ist also ich rate
jedem mal sich immer anzuschauen wie
gesagt tu berlin - ruhepunkt nett wenn
mich nicht alles täuscht kann ich
nochmal die beschreibung schreiben
genauso ich lasse mir was für ein
wunderschöner nicht die schreiber ist
auf jeden fall
schaut euch den x server hier wird auf
einen ziemlich coolen team gemacht unter
anderem moya minecraft und league sind
da ganz vorne mit dabei
man kennt ja auch ein bisschen länger
toll tanz oder was oder ganz schön
rentnern und erschafft sich war
wie kann man so weit sein der kommt
jetzt kommen kollegen
ttg alter allein hast du keine chance
man runter ich hoffe ich habe auch keine
payback punkte so die dächer der jetzt
gerade geholfen hat muss jetzt auch
dafür büssen der schule gebracht und ihm
lieb ist ist jetzt hier gut positioniert
ist auch eine gute strategie
man kann hier nicht so den eco modus
macht man muss zusammen bleiben sonst
wird mir getroffen dahin habt ihr das
gesehen
oh da muss man das level 1 falls ich
eine wirklich getroffen aber es sah für
mich so aus dass zwei herzen und ich
glaub ich warte bis ich sterbe damit ich
dann vor wenn ich mir die
vollautomatische aber ist okay ich
wollte mich zwar nicht gut für mein team
aber auch sonst gutes equipment ab und
dann zeigen wir euch mal was man ja
alles so tolles kaufen kann im shop da
jetzt noch eine display da hinten haben
wir noch eine kiste äpfel sagt okay 12
und jetzt schon mal / ob zac hier kann
man unter anderem günstig einkaufen
hilfe package würde paul also seine
giftpfeile kripo pfeile wirkaufens ist
die vollautomatische ja den
vollautomatischen
die frau hatte waschen bogen junge du
kriegst du rhum malta oder geräuschen
den grünen die gläubiger ich stehe
gerade deshalb jetzt payback payback
payback
das ist in bad ischl und sein leben
jetzt so richtig schön auf rechts bild
einfach gedrückt halten und die leute
auseinandernehmen sagte ja ich glaube
aber dass teil eine begrenzte
haltbarkeit bin mir nicht ganz sicher
auf jeden fall läuft es gerade jetzt nur
noch golf lang gratis
es ist nur leider ging love ist und ihr
wissen wir zusammen gold hier zusammen
wir wollen dahin
nein auch fraglich war auf dem boden wo
man jetzt gerade meine meinung
und es ist richtig knapp 1 team führt
noch 4 km führt leider ist leider so ich
hoffe mein gott wir haben nur drei leben
und ihr seht wenn da wenn die lebender
weg sind also die die leise
der stand der rechts auf 0 gelaufen ist
eines teams dann ist das team ramos als
eliminiert anders die runde sozusagen
verloren ich hoffe
dass unser team love is jetzt hier ein
bisschen zusammenbleiben kann und wir
wissen was reißen können
ja ich dachte junge ist das knapp alter
jetzt drauf wird wir müssen für unser
team kämpfen wir haben noch einen kann
ein
noch ein leben haben wir da waren so
viele da waren zu viele da weiß aber wie
kommt man dann noch eine kurze runde
machen so wieder wählen unsere kisten
versuchen wir das bekommen auch die wenn
alles was man kriegen kann ja auch nice
wir schauen welches team wir sind
team-gold und ich bin ramon ist team
diamond machen es einfach noch schnelle
runde
wenn ich auf das die runde hier nicht
allzu lange her da kommt da schon da
kommt natürlich mache ich erstmal die
ramon maschine läuft die ganze daher
mich davon zu erwischen
40 sekunden dann freue mich aber lieber
installieren kommt aber ohne nur schwert
kommt nein wird ja wohl kannste nix ne
ich kann mit bogen mehr gleich
verdienten darunter dahinter laufen
drauf getroffen
da kann doch einer vom anderen ja ich
weiß aber ich habe drei pfeile und der
andere hat die letzten folgen waren halb
fünf leute gegen mich aber echt lustig
an die sagen dann richtig freuen sich
schlachttier
ja ich gestaunt hat immer noch ab ich
warte auch ich warte auf dem moment
nehmen wir als gegen eins machen
ich bin gespannt wie das ausgeht ich
glaube sagt der typ der teckboten setzt
was was wäre der gomez ging typ dann
aber das ist fast der hat gerade ein
dreierteam einfach so der diesem blog
schlag die ganze zeit so irgendwie eine
millisekunde schnell gemacht und alle
getötet alter kann ich sagen es war mein
alter der stand um die schöne junge es
ist tag alle mit zwei hinweg gefallen
hat
du hast mich in alter floorball wo genau
der bastard der ist ein doofer scheiß
hacker und ich gleich jetzt mal
angenommen du kleiner da leider leider
leider haben wir haben wieder unsere
vier leben aber ich glaube die warten
lieber ab bis da bis wir dann wieder
purzeln dann wieder response werden wir
wollen leben
da oben wir holen in der weg ist nicht
die häuser
natürlich ist es nicht einfach so wir
renditen herrscht der grenze liegen
ein neuer trend auf instagram
freudige instagram mittelalter ach
stichwort instagram leute ihr könnt
gerne mal unter exakt folgen haben sich
schon ein paar tolle menschen versammelt
darauf wird es nicht kommen afag zu zwei
dabei habe ich eine erwischt ja ich habe
überall noch erwischt die gegen 82 geht
es war gut eine schlichte ab
trotzdem noch wichtiger ist widmen da da
haben wir doch alles leider nicht alles
aber ein bisschen was
und wir holen jetzt vor allen dingen mal
mit / ob unsere gute alte stickiger sehr
gut sehr gut und dann geht's ab dann
gibt es ab und dieser stick gegangen die
sticky dann ist sozusagen die essenz des
postens wenn man so will war einfach so
ultra schnelle erfolg das einfach
niemals machen können und die pfeile
machen auch ordentlichen schaden
fakt ist gesehen die haben kein land
gesehen gegen mich habe ich kaum
getroffen und da komme ich zurecht guten
partie gesagt und für alles in allem
wirklichen daumen hoch vielen spielen wo
das würde ich sagen der ich blute die
füße die ich glaube ich schleiche mich
hier so rum und irgendwann wieder von
hinten an
falls das klappt ob es klappt nicht ja
ist klar wahrscheinlich das ist so ein
fakt
das ist nicht nur unglaublich das ist
echt ohne witz hat gesagt dass es nicht
unglaublich nein der spaß effekt
wirklich leute wenn ihr endlich
aufgenommen hätte hätte das gesehen
alters weg sich von der seite
er ist nicht normal alter der typ also
ich habe jetzt niemand gesehen da der
migros hektar weil er ja und dann bist
du affe wie team-gold abschluss das gibt
es ja nicht
ich hole mir die ganze zeit die kills
genau die typische an deinem themen data
aber und team gold cup ja keine ahnung
weil er einfach trotzdem stirbt nicht
sein so kraska es sein
dieser komme typ einen dissens zu
einfach stick schirmer als schirmer du
weisst nicht ob du hättest direkt ohne
witz guckt erstmal jetzt gut wieder
schlägt der leute auf die stelle eine
kleine den habe ich jetzt geholt
ihr könnte man die kommentare schreiben
leider passen für den monsters zehn
junge der greift dich doch nicht an
lasst es kann doch nur das kann doch nur
die comments on sunshine nähe aber wie
ich ich stand ja gerade eben daneben und
habe sozusagen verfolgt wie er da
geschlagen hat ja trotzdem aller der hat
der typ mit googles kern subtilen
dagestanden das kannst du gar nicht
selber erkennen weil du eben nicht in
dem tier überleben nicht im gegner team
bis jetzt weil er dich nicht schlagen
kann
da hat mich eingeschlagen wie sie im
chart und hat mir ein hippie hat er mich
denke wie konnte so viel einstecken
neu krass na ja auf jeden fall leute ihr
könnt gerne einen daumen da lassen nach
oben das am besten
und auch wenn der ball aber liebe dich
und in die kommentare schreiben wie ich
das gefallen dann schau doch einfach mal
vorbei
ramona beschreibung könnte ich auch
anschauen sie beschreibt
natürlich sagen bis zunächst video
dramaturg